[Music]
three
two one action hey guys welcome back to
off the record where we talk about
whatever we want
[Music]
[Applause]
yay we got nikki what is that
oh this is how i make fire dude oh there
we go
um i know you guys just did a no chaser
game
and uh i wanted to bring tim on this
week
but i know that he was filming so i know
that's probably going to be impossible
but i did see on instagram that he has
a baby coming he does have a baby you
tell me what the hell's happening
because he doesn't want to tell me
what do you mean what's happening chia
and tim
and they made a baby i know but i'm so
excited for them i know
i feel like he posted up also he's in
the new
drake video i saw he's in the new drake
video and the justin bieber video yes
people are drinking he's like i feel
like more people are excited about
drake than his baby he was like so baby
drake what is going on well because
they're like you've been busting
yeah you've been busted nuts so i get it
but
damn to be in a drake thing that's true
you made it he was like i was a
background person in a drake video
that's still
further than i've ever been he's like my
baby drake video no you're the [ __ ]
about uh unfamous baby within the same
week so yeah no uh he does they don't
know what it is yet but you guys
they're everybody waiting to wait right
yeah i was like this is how you know you
have money
when you can wait for the gender because
i need to know so people bring the right
gifts to the baby shower
when do you find out what the gender is
uh remember within the first three
months
yeah he knows so how long has it been i
don't know
what three months well he's like so he's
been hiding it for that long
yeah he's been hiding it for that long
my baby is 12 years old
he his baby's three years old so he
knows more than i do now
okay but then even for me because he's
three now because i'm sorry
i'm starting to forget right no because
his is more recent more fresh
oh god and it's just like yeah it's like
she's talking you're asking her
something that happened to first grade
for her pretty much
yeah that's like 12 12 years right she's
like uh
have no clue who knows but hopefully we
get to know again
because we're we're trying oh congrats
tim then said they uh when they decided
to try
it was like a solid a week of effort and
then next thing you know they got it and
he was like wow yeah
on the first week of what's their
definition of a week though like five
times a day no it was literally he was
like
they were exhausted like yeah also they
were trying i was talking to chia that
whole day that they announced it i
literally
talked to her like texting for freaking
essays like
paragraphs because like just sharing her
that's what i was trying to do with tim
but you know when two dudes talk they
don't talk very well
it's just sentences at a time like yo
that's crazy and he goes yeah
and i'm like cool boy or girl we don't
know
i'm like i and i'm like zero emphasis
you're not gonna tell you when the due
date was or anything no
you probably don't even know he's asking
me about tim i don't talk to tim like
that y'all
i found out in person he told me and i
was like oh that's super dope
he's like you know letting everybody
know before it goes on instagram i'm
like
he didn't tell me before it got on
instagram because he was here
we're not his real friend i guess oh you
guys didn't make the
the video the reaction video no no i
mean if it makes you feel better i
didn't make it either so
haha but you got told in person i didn't
get told we got told through instagram
so
what did she tell you because i want to
know you got the inside scoop because if
you talk to chia you know exactly what's
going on i do
and and right now i'm contemplating
whether or not i should even say because
it's not my business to share you know
so i i don't know that's my business to
know
i was like i'll share tim's business but
his business is different
i should do uh one of those like
reaction videos again but telling people
he's in the drake video oh my god
and seeing how much his family reacted
that would be really funny your brain he
gets way more views on that yeah i bet
he would
everybody was super excited about the
baby but then it was like
big news and then bigger news it got
[ __ ] over there
you think if it was released the other
way around have been it would have been
like
that's why tim needs a manager his
release is all [ __ ] up
yeah you gotta work on the release of
the freak come out first and then baby
afterwards because he knew that video
was coming out
yeah yeah like it's not like they just
filmed the next day after he released
said pregnancy yeah
we didn't talk about it we just talked
about it on the podcast too the whole
like the whole experience of both of
them back to back and he's like
uh do you tell people you're in a drake
video without sounding like a groupie
like how do you
how do you do that without sounding like
true i'm in a drake video
i think he did it the right way because
if you tell people right people have
like high standards so they're like
oh i'm in a drake video so you're
looking for every single frame
that you're dapping up with drake you're
in the shots that are like this
well you didn't watch the videos not
even in it bieber's in it
yeah that's what i'm saying no but if
you tell people that's what they expect
right
and then when they watch the video it's
a giant letdown
so you can't so if you just don't say it
then when you see them pop up you're
like
zero expectations right well tim you
guys haven't heard his theory about uh
the episodes of walla now he literally
would wait so the tweets went up on
um on twitter to see on the east coast
so like the episode comes out then he'd
wait to tell people on the west coast
depending on if there's like a lot of
reaction
like oh so it's like oh everybody's
reacting on the east coast cool now i'm
gonna tell everybody to go
and watch it on the west coast so that
he's not like check out my episode and
he's not so whacked oh of course yeah oh
because he doesn't know the dream right
he's just wait like a week and then make
the announcement
didn't he know when the launch was no i
think i think everybody
else made the announcement for him like
people started tweeting
people started tweeting him and he's
like yeah because it's not his project
so why would he know exactly when it
would come out
so he's probably like hey i want to tell
people about my baby
right he's like i can do this yeah i
think the world found out about tim in
the drake video before
true but enough about her tim i want to
know about you girl have you been
i'm good how you been with tim
well you know we just shot yesterday and
told him i was gonna be on here today
but
yeah no i'm good working no chaser radio
just gotta um i'm on a new job
not yet oh i did get one can't say that
kind of [ __ ]
no not yet there's some big stuff coming
but um a weekend show
um called the basement so now that's
gonna be playing with it b-a-y-s
basement ss like base base like bay
like like in the bay area i thought it
was bays
so they were being cute yeah it's like
it's
base mint uh yeah so a syndicated show
with dj erock it's going to be
syndicated means that it's on multiple
stations oh so it's in
la palm springs san francisco um
vegas it's big in vegas um yep so i'm on
that
morning show and just working and here
so you do a lot of audio like stuff
talk a [ __ ] lot yeah i talk a lot how
did you know you were good at
talking i didn't somebody else did
i was good at not talking you got
scouted for your for your talking
talking skills yeah
shut the [ __ ] up and make me some money
let's do that
i was on uh snapchat actually remember
snapchat was like
super popping at one time and people
used to do takeovers and i was doing
takeovers
and a friend of mine was working at the
station that i'm at currently
called uh kaywin and he said you ever
thought about doing radio you speak very
well and i'm like
why like why why would i do radio don't
you see i put
you know how well you speak you speak so
well that gio
uh when she after she filmed for the
first time she was like
watch how nikki speaks it's extremely
impressive because i've never heard her
say a single um and this whole time i
was listening
and i'm like there's no [ __ ] um
[ __ ]
oh my god i don't know i'm not gonna be
like it
um someone naturally yeah it's awkward
that's the most awkward i'm ever heard
okay i wrote down words that i
said repeatedly when i first got into
radio wait so you listen to yourself and
then you were like okay i said this way
too many times hate listening to myself
i think i don't like listening
to myself and don't like watching myself
i have no idea most of the times when
stuff is out
yeah me too i don't watch it i don't re
i i don't
every once in a while i'll go just like
critique myself and so i was like okay
i say man a lot when i don't know what
to say next
when i'm working that's your um i'll be
like me and
then
this coffee bomb and then i go back
i'm like [ __ ] i said man a lot and i
write down the word man
and i circle it and i cross it out wow
you are a professional yeah you actually
work out your crap yeah cause i don't do
that
i just go [ __ ] that's dope and i play
myself again and again and again and
again
it's different than when you have
somebody like higher up that listens to
everything you say and i'm like yo i'd
rather take care of this myself before
somebody else tells me
right because it ain't fun when you got
to sit in an office and they're like so
we're gonna have to really work on a
couple things with you and you're like
that's true because when i'm the boss i
could be perfect you can say whatever
you want
nobody gets a [ __ ] you can be like um i
don't i'm in um
what um excuse me man that's actually
funny if i said that
um um yeah like do you ever have a
dreams when you like
like like totally and when i said like
the way elon musk speaks
he drives me crazy like it's not like
monotone and like
pretty slow no it's not just the slow i
mean the slow and the monotone for sure
and the cadence
it's the cadence yeah it's like yes it's
a slower version of christopher walken
it's like it's just a weird rhythm
i find that soothing some reason do you
think it's because he's high
no he always seems like he has a dry
mouth too i think he's too smart because
he's like one of those guys you're like
oh how's your morning he goes
well it depends on what you defined by
morning is it the east coast or it's not
that fast no
in his brain right so he goes he goes so
he's thinking
all these things will be defined by
morning are you talking about like the
gravitational pull or whatever and then
he's like
it was nice and then so he's just going
through so much [ __ ]
where i think like it's it's really
really difficult for him i need to
listen because i
don't listen to him talk oh yeah yeah
it's pretty it's
like this when you name your baby xyz or
you know
number hashtag i don't know i can't
trust and you know when the show gets
boring it's time to bring out our
sponsor
today's video is brought to you by
draftkings baby yep
so now is the time to celebrate because
football is finally back i know a lot of
football fans have been waiting when are
you guys going to play finally because
the nba has been playing well guess what
football is back and you can get in on
the action by signing up
with draftkings nothing adds to the
excitement of watching the game quite
like having a shot at millions of
dollars in prizes for those of you guys
that don't know draftkings it's like a
fantasy league
and uh you get to choose your players
and you get to build pretty much your
own team and depending on how they play
in real life
is how your team does in fantasy and it
makes you even
more invested in not just your team but
the entire league now
so that's why i really really like
playing fantasy league
and draftkings has paid out billions of
dollars to winner since 2012 so they
know
a thing or two about cold hard cash it's
simple just pick your lineup stay under
the salary cap and see
how your team stacks up against the
competition that's right so download the
draftkings app now and use
code off the record for a limited time
new users can get a free shot at
millions of dollars in prizes with your
first deposit
that's called off the record only at
draftkings
make it rain baby thank you draftkings
minimum five
dollar deposit required eligibility
restrictions apply
see draftkings.com for details baby
thank you draftkings but yeah the reason
why elon musk drives me crazy because i
can hear myself
as well when i'm trying to speak and i'm
trying to articulate and i get stuck
because my brain is working too fast and
my mouth can't keep up with it and my
tongue gets
caught up and so i'm always like
like i don't know like how do you how do
you manage
like how do you manage to articulate so
well do this thing so we took like a uh
one of our favorite improv comedy
classes there's this guy named rich
talarico is one of my favorite
instructors shout outs to ray shout outs
to rich
um he he voiced something in a way that
i've never really put it in that
mindset before but i really like and he
calls it rolling visualization
so rolling visualization is like as
you're doing something you're already
seeing two or three steps ahead
and the more comfortable you get at
stuff so like let's say you're brushing
your teeth right
if you see like a cup floating on the
sink about the file you just grab and
put it on
but you just have to be that comfortable
where you can kind of do one thing and
see another thing
um and i notice i think people that are
really good at hosting they kind of have
this ability to have this conversation
right now but also think about where i
want to take it and what else is
happening is that yeah also what's going
on in your brain i'm way better at
improv than i am at reading script
me too way better i get nervous like
i'll start getting sweaty and i'm like i
know how to read like
but as soon as you're sure like
sometimes i'm sure
sometimes i'm not the eligibility gets
you know stumbled upon those words
eligibility restrictions see i could do
it if i'm not reading it commercials
mess me up right every once in a while i
get nervous because i don't sound like
myself anymore
it goes into like a different voice like
you the voice you think you're supposed
to sound like
i have that problem but when we're
talking i can pick up on people
and i can read your body language so i
can almost see when i'm supposed to talk
and i had to learn that part but if
there's an end goal in mind i know where
it's supposed to go
like when you guys cut a commercial you
are waiting for that moment to say your
part
but you're waiting for it and you're
like okay i can see when i'm supposed to
talk so same thing
very similar and i and always talk about
what you know and that's your fallback
always fall back on what you know what
if you don't know that much opposite
yeah
i pretend like i know everything and
then later people get mad they're like
that's not true joe
and then you're like okay sure then you
look it up and you're like completely
wrong yep like i said something like a
few weeks ago where i was like oh if you
drop a penny
it could kill you from with the empire
stability i thought that's what like
everyone knew i thought
that that's not yeah but they disproved
it so many years ago and everyone was
like clowning on me
yeah but it's funny though because what
ends up happening is
they have conversation because how
stupid you are yeah and i'm like
[ __ ] yeah do it and then i get to learn
without having to search google yeah
people just dm me and go
actually yeah that's true a lot of
people i feel like when they troll us
for saying something stupid i don't
think they even know they they have no
they got the luxury of googling it first
before writing that comment and then
everyone's like bandwagoning on that or
they
just learned it they yeah they just
learned it in history class or whatever
they're like actually there's nothing
worse than getting that
damn dm that's like first off
cardi b's album came out six months ago
not six
years ago and i'm like first of all did
you listen to what i
said because that's how it gets first of
all first of all i will fight you
zero of all i will fight you i actually
reply
i got time sometimes i got tired
some days i am like the universe told me
not to do this
you are so funny the universe told me
today is not the day
you are forgiven you're having a really
rough day aren't you
and other days the universe is like [ __ ]
her up i'm like
all right i need spell check somebody
proofread this before i said
before i destroy i'ma i'm about to add
her
i had bosses hit me up and like please
don't
nikki can you please stop posting some
of the stuff people send you in your dms
cause like
um you can't be calling them out all the
time and i'm like
but they're racist i need to show them
they're like
it's really not good for your brand i'm
like it's part of the brand
i think it's good for the brand some you
gotta i had somebody
legitimately write me and i didn't post
it
i didn't i wanted to but i could hear i
could hear that i could hear the call
coming in
nikki take it down i could hear it nikki
take it down
you have a lot of work you're about to
do take it down yeah
because now i have people watching
everything i do like
don't [ __ ] up our money if you don't do
this right but the guy legitimately
wrote me and said you're so pretty too
bad you only like black and brown like
uh black girls and guys
what black girls and guys that's what
they said you're so pretty you're
bisexually black
apparently and i saw and i saw that
and it wasn't a troll account because
they actually had followers and i just
was so disappointed i was like
what did you think you were
accomplishing with this like what what
was that
like why obviously you're wrong because
she likes black girls guys
and one asian guy thank you to all of
you guys uh
shipping this because like we see all
the comments oh that wouldn't be all the
comments
i have a catchphrase for you what is
that nikki blades
i'll cut you out oh
i like that i'll cut you then when i get
caught up having a knife in my backpack
you'll be like that's not me it's not me
but your name is nikki blades i'll cut
you on your iv
can you explain can you please explain
this knife in your bag it wasn't me
someone planted it he did it that's what
he called man
the universe told me today you know
that's a roll of the dice we don't know
what nick we don't
i don't know what nicki we getting some
days you know i don't know i wake up and
i'm like
it's exciting imagine dating me
keep you on your toes that's why we're
single
by choice good for you until he's ready
no that's great yeah because uh honestly
yeah doing this job and
the fact that i'm the one that has the
stories the news articles and stuff and
and most of the times the articles that
i do have
don't have the entire story so then by
the time the video comes out and then
they get to see it
they're like you missed all this
information and i'm like
they will hate you prep services i deal
with the prep service too
you just decide you want to read it as
soon as you get on air and as you're
reading it you're realizing the story is
all the way wrong and you're like
well we're going to come back to this
that's happened that's happened multiple
times
it's life yeah it's live it's worth it
when you come back to what do you do in
the meantime
and then how do you fix it so you let
people know that it's like you're
messing up you have to be okay with
saying that you've messed up and the
information might be wrong you cannot
pretend to be right all the time that's
how you get away exhausting that's how
you get away i pretend to be wrong
on purpose the best way it's the best
way
don't pretend to be smart and not know
[ __ ] that's why i open
this guy because they'll call you out
but there's nothing worse than reading
the article
and then seeing immediately after that
it was wrong
or something was missing but you just
gotta talk about it sometimes i blame
the prep service a million times i say
you know whoever's writing these
articles needs to give the full story
how dare they misinform you through me
[Laughter]
nice their fault that's what you blame
them cnn whoever wrote it around and go
i'm on your side
i'm on your side i didn't [ __ ] up here
no i'm just merely
a vessel yeah no that's why i'm always
like i'm not afraid to look dumb anymore
i'm just like hey
listen whatever i want to look at like
you know what people like do they want
to be a perfect parent
on camera in my vlogs i'm taika don't i
beat you
tell the world and i [ __ ] beat your
ass and i abuse you there's nothing
better than actually being smart and
above people
and pretending that you're dumb that's
the model i live by
and you can [ __ ] buy that is that
your new
like did i miss it has that been your
tagline is that your thing no i just
made it up oh i like that
the whole look thank you it's like uh
i have money here but not here in here
but here's a lot of cash to prove it and
i got good credit you can't see
it but i got it but my hat's expensive
i'll confuse you
i'm like homeless here but not here i
just went on vacation here
but here we're working for the vacation
that i just went on
[Music]
you